what's wrong with people what's wrong
with
people naked also squirrel they ain't
got no edit
button you can trim that
out right right before the
ass why you ass naked with a baby
squirrel man what you doing all right
hold on hold on wait a minute
that let that get out he had to release
it he had to release that he had to look
at that clip and be like that's
fine and I'm going to upload it oh my
God if I could be inside the Chipmunks
mind for two seconds I'm going
get Frey tell these folks how freaky
your freaky ass is watch this playing
with us Chipmunks all the time and
nobody here to defend us against your
naked
I'm sending this Alvin
Simon I got real tears in my
eyes I did not expect
that naked
ass what what type of freaky AB in
the world people Los mind baby
chip Mon oh my God why you ass
naked with the squirrel in your head at
the
camera doesn't jump out at me I think
you I think you hope oh God all right
all right let's go
listen he had me fool he talk I thought
it was humanitarian he's like it's so
cute just be careful cuz you don't want
him to jump out he was about to put the
squirrel in his
ass oh God literally crying right now oh
God oh God all right all right you ready
come on all right I'm sorry man can't do
it like that help get his meditation I'm
sorry here we go all right
listen if you made it this far that mean
that you're you're against squirrels
going in people's asses just
like I am okay you better finish when
she
started